[Music]
johnny johnny hurry up
[Applause]
let's go adios everybody come on we
don't have time for cheat check we've
got to get through this jungle if we're
going to find a crystal
johnny
we're getting nowhere
don't worry drak i got you covered huh
and the final touch
now you're ready for the great outdoors
fine okay whatever can we please just
get going hold up
you forgot your trunk
okay let's find that crystal
hiking
[Music]
aren't the sounds of nature soothing
[Music]
ugh what is that smell
oh what is that
it's me track chill you just need a
shower and where am i going to find the
shower in the middle of the jungle
[Music]
hey i think you might have a pollen
allergy
yes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey how
am i so late
and yet completely
try
okay
how
much further
huh
no no no no no
we are never going to get there
whoa drag
isn't that something
water
thank you i am melting
hold on drak you got to be extra careful
with strange bodies of water this one
time my friend kamachi and i were
backpacking in thailand
drake
[Applause]
well look on the bright side at least
you're not hot anymore
[Music]
man why didn't anyone tell me that claws
are so awesome
whoa
being a monster is super weird ah
yeah
but being a human is the worst oh come
on i wouldn't say that really
blisters sunburn and swamp butt aren't
the worst what was that
yeah
mosquito vampires of the jungle hey i
resent that
[Music]
they're everywhere
johnny's they're all over you
what
monster skin
don't worry drak you can't fight me
on january 14th family movie night is
getting revamped only on prime video
for centuries no human has had the power
to become a monster until now
but is this safe though let's find out
[Music]
is everything okay down here hey drac
what's up oops
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
you're human drag dad
oh no i have a total dad bod
[Music]
[Music]
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me i've literally
never seen you before
there is a place deep in the amazon only
there can the transformations be
reversed time to go
stereo man
if we don't fix you guys soon you'll be
like this forever
being a human is the worst
mosquito
hotel transylvania transfer mania
boy that was fun
ready pg coming january 14th only on
prime video
[Music]
you